il y a de nouveau numéro inédit de gérer
dormir chez vous on est fan absolu euh
qui arrive demain soir à 21h10 sur RMC
découverte je vous emmène en Serbie oui
j'adore alors on va regarder la
bande-annonce tu vas nous raconter tout
ça là vous allez kiffer avec moulant on
va se détendre on en a besoin qui est
déjà lancé Serbie non d'accord
Jean-Michel bah pendant la guerre
d'accord et toi
d'accord moi j'étais rue François de
Serbie
la livraison allez c'est parti
il fait beau je suis en pleine nature
que demander de plus et hop c'est parti
je sais pas pourquoi mais j'ai la pêche
il ne peut pas se passer d'aller chez
les autres
enfin d'essayer bonjour madame ok bye
bye facov yes ok je vais faire ça un
épisode inédit
j'y vais vraiment inédit
j'irai dormir chez vous en Serbie
vendredi à 21h10 sur RMC découverte et
RMC BFM play
ça sera demain à 21h10 sur RMC
découverte alors sans tout dévoiler en
Serbie des habitants ils ont une
particularité c'est qu'ils aiment bien
boire il y en a oui ça arrive ça
t'arrive souvent alors de tes voyages
alors il y a un jeune homme qui te dit
que c'est pour la digestion et pour
éviter de trop picoler parce que
l'alcool est dangereux pour la santé
bien sûr tu as une technique que je ne
connaissais pas c'est celle du verre
d'eau regardez la technique donc
c'est pas attaquer comme ça merci
beaucoup
je vais pouvoir utiliser ma vieille
technique qui consiste à boire le verre
dans la bouche et le recracher dans le
verre d'eau ça c'est très près alors
démonstration extrêmement efficace
[Rires]
[Musique]
et voilà
l'alcool est dans le verre d'eau
[Rires]
c'est 10h du matin
j'aime bien les dans les pays que je ne
connais pas c'est ça parce que non mais
c'est fou j'étais sûr qui était allé moi
non non
il reste combien de pays ce que tu as
fait combien de pays en toi
110 à peu près et pour la série
66e épisode
67 le prochain alors tu es parti aussi
au Vietnam sera la semaine prochaine 28
avril tu nous emmènes au Vietnam
regarder
prochain Antoine de Maximy débarque
enfin au Vietnam tu peux entrer et rien
ne l'arrête boire un petit verre
je sais pas si je suis invité à manger
rien ne le déstabilise et abominable
sauf d'être aussi bien accueilli c'est
pas normal
[Musique]
un épisode et un accueil inédit au
Vietnam les gens les plus accueillants
du monde Antoine de Maximy
alors à la base tu devrais la Taïwan oui
pourquoi ça s'est passé mais parce que
j'arrive à Taïwan je comptais vraiment
rester 15 jours et je m'aperçois que ils
ont le masque dans l'aéroport ils ont le
masque dans les rues ils ont le masque
en intérieur à la campagne alors je me
suis pas embêté je me suis dit je vais
pas tourner dans ces conditions-là ça va
pas être drôle j'ai regardé les pays qui
n'étaient pas loin j'étais jamais allé
au Vietnam tant que je le Vietnam cool
c'est tranquille ta vie hein
mais c'est ça exactement est-ce que les
Français sont bien accueillis alors ça
dépend des pays mais dans l'ensemble en
tout cas au Vietnam est en Serbie oui
mais c'est quoi le pays où on est on a
été le plus mal accueilli alors en fait
c'est assez bizarre les c'est pas
forcément mal accueilli mais c'est
difficile par exemple les Émirats
c'était compliqué d'accord parce que
quand il y a un mariage il y a une fête
pour les hommes et une fête pour les
femmes donc toi tu arrives tu veux
dormir chez les gens et ils connaissent
pas ils ont juste qu'il passe à la télé
française ou c'est quand même pas tout à
fait aussi sage donc c'était difficile
mais paradoxalement à des pays les plus
accueillants c'est le Maroc donc là
c'est pas une histoire de religion en
tout cas
et le pays dont c'est vraiment c'était
c'est le top c'est quoi le pays que tu
as préféré préférer j'en sais rien mais
en tout cas le Vietnam c'est hyper
accueillant mais alors j'en revenais pas
je comprenais pas et le pays la plus
belle aventure TV c'est quoi je crois
que avec du recul maintenant c'est la
traversée de l'Inde parce que je suis
parti avec au début en train après en
bus après j'ai acheté une voiture une
ambassadeur que j'avais peint à faire
repeindre finalement entre en rouge et
jaune et ça ressemble à une vieille 403
et j'ai traversé toute l'Inde pendant
trois mois tout seul et le film
s'appelle j'irai dormir à Bollywood qui
est la suite plus ou moins du film
j'irai dormir à Hollywood c'est ça qui
était sorti au cinéma en 2008 alors et
on va voir un épisode où tu te balades
en scooter tu tombes sur une fête de
prémariage là tous les invités
t'accueils comme si tu étais des leurs
alors forcément il te servent à boire
mais aussi à manger notamment un truc
pas ouf regardez
on mange comment ok
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va très bien
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mangé au Vietnam c'est quoi c'est
quoi le truc le plus mauvais c'est une
sauce qui est faite à partir de
crevettes pourries
quand même bah j'ai fini ma bouche
je reconnais que
c'est vrai que sans rigoler tu dois être
immunisé toi tu as mangé des trucs de
foot tu as vu des trucs quand même les
sauces qui sont mauvais comme là mais
qu'il y en a beaucoup en Inde etc c'est
en général c'est pour masquer la
pourriture de la viande que la viande
est pourrie on met de la sauce qui est
très forte pour masquer la brutale
c'était une expédition c'était avant
j'irai dormir chez vous j'arrive au camp
une belle expédition et j'arrive au camp
et ça puait une odeur abominable je dis
mais qu'est-ce que c'est mais c'est la
viande le cuisinier me dit ça il s'est
dit mais on va pas la manger d'ici mais
c'est à cause du congélateur le groupe
arrête pas de s'arrêter donc ça congèle
ça décongèle
[Musique]
il dit pas du tout je vais la faire
cuire quatre heures et personne sera
malade et bah personne était malade mais
chose cette affaire
n'hésite pas à commenter
honnêtement c'est ce qui m'amuse parce
que si moi je m'amusais pas je
continuerai pas je fais pas ça pour
travailler comme ça ça se prépare pas
c'est pas nécessaire
comment tu choisis ta destination alors
normalement c'est selon mes envies et
parce que il faut vraiment être motivé
si tu vas à contrecoeur ça ira bien sûr
et là particulièrement comme c'est les
20 ans de gérer dormir chez vous on a
fait un petit jeu où il choisit entre
trois pays Paraguay Botswana Lettonie et
bah j'attends le résultat d'accord c'est
quoi c'est quoi le pays dont tu rêvais
au départ et et voilà alors il y a dans
les endroits où vraiment j'aimerais
aller il y a la Corée du Nord le jour où
son pourra y aller ça va être un saut
dans l'espace-temps absolument
incroyable parce que un pays qui est
coupé depuis des décennies forcément
tout est différent et puis l'Antarctique
mais c'est pas évident d'y aller non
plus je peux t'amener chez Picard à côté
non moi je voulais lui poser une
question si on veut faire Antoine de
Maximy oui il faut combien d'argent faut
partir avec combien d'argent c'est pas
cher c'est que à part le billet d'avion
le billet d'avion comment tu sais on
sécurise comment parce que s'il y a des
gens c'est comme quand tu pars en
vacances tu sécurises pas ah non quand
même quand je pars en vacances j'ai tout
loué à l'avant j'ai mis ma carte bleue
alors quand tu partais en vacances quand
tu avais 18 ans avec la 4L comment tu
fais alors le 19 chamade là je partais
au ski mais on avait déjà réservé
l'appartement
c'était sécurisé on partait pas comme ça
dans un pays qu'on connaît pas c'est
faisable
ouais il m'a même temps il faut il faut
être vigilant non il faut être vigilant
toi qui a vu tous les pays c'est quoi le
pays où on est le mieux où il fait on
vit le mieux c'est ici mais oui il y a
que quand tu as voyager que tu comprends
que la France c'est si c'est pas le
meilleur pays du monde c'est un des
meilleurs non vraiment mais oui parce
que déjà si on parle de paysage c'est un
jardin la France tellement c'est varié
on a tout il nous montre que la banquise
quoi
des dunes on a tout et puis sinon je
veux dire socialement on a des aides on
a des machins on est on est on est
vraiment c'est quand même super sécurisé
quoi plein de niveaux c'est sincèrement
je vais vous dire un truc et là je pense
sincèrement nos vois sincèrement c'est
quand même
il faut pas casser ce pays
on a on a des meilleurs pays du monde
vraiment c'est quoi le regard des des
autres pays sur la France qu'on a
l'impression moi j'ai eu un truc moi qui
j'ai eu l'impression par exemple pendant
la finale de la Coupe du Monde argentine
- France qui avait beaucoup plus de pays
qui était pour l'Argentine que pour la
France c'est-à-dire que la France j'ai
l'impression que plus ça va plus la
France on est les on est les malaimés
tout le monde moi chaque fois que je
donne un pays on me dit vous donner des
leçons à tout le monde et vous êtes nul
vous êtes nul en tout voilà ce qu'il y a
rien c'est vrai l'image des Français
c'est ça on me dit les Américains m'ont
dit vous donner des soins tout le monde
et vous êtes nul en tout cas en Serbie
lié au Vietnam a vraiment ah ouais en
Serbie ils aiment bien les Français ah
bah c'est bien
je suis français
merci merci
au Vietnam vous arrivez chez les gens
ils vous accueille tellement bien et
vous propose de rester dormir chez eux
que vous vous demandez si vous en parc
connu via Internet vous arrive souvent
ça non ça arrive pas très souvent non là
mais je pense que c'est un pays qui est
tellement accueillant je sais pas j'ai
même eu peur aussi d'un truc c'est que
ils osent pas me dire non mais là c'est
simplement qui en plus il me proposait
j'avais rien demandé
est-ce que lors de vos voyages vous avez
parfois un gros coup de flip prends une
panique à bord
c'est arrivé c'est arrivé mais pas à
chaque fois et quand il y a une
fusillade plus derrière toi c'est pas
très à l'aise quand en Bolivie en 2006
il y a une fausse policière qui me dit
de monter dans un taxi pour aller au
commissariat etc qui a un truc qui se
fait parce qu'ils ont pas de voiture de
police en tout cas à l'époque j'ai pas
voulu y aller ça a été un attroupement
des gens pris ma défense etc mais le
lendemain enfin quelques jours plus tard
j'ai appris que ses amis parce que elle
a passé quelques jours en prison ses
amis me cherchaient alors là pas très à
l'aise et j'ai quitté le pays un peu
précipitamment parce que tu peux pas
essayer de rencontrer des gens que tu
connais pas quand il y a des gens que tu
connais pas qui veulent te coincer j'ai
une technique pour ça je veux bien je
suis preneur alors je vais bien j'ai une
technique pour toi je te jure que c'est
vrai ça marche tout le temps quand il y
a un mec qui te cherche qu'est-ce que tu
fais tu l'appelles
tu dis non il paraît que tu me cherches
bah quand j'aurai raccroché c'est moi
qui vais te chercher voilà c'est tout à
partir de maintenant
ça marche tout le temps
exactement
est-ce que tu te rappelles de ton
premier voyage
c'est le premier voyage où je me
retrouve dans un pays où je peux pas
parler du tout et j'ai fait un deuxième
coup de poker c'est que j'ai dit à la
chaîne à l'époque c'était voyage je leur
ai dit que je partais au Maroc et puis
finalement je me suis dit c'est
peut-être le dernier épisode je suis
jamais au Japon je suis allé au Japon
mais je le répète c'est incroyable alors
regardez regardez et tu voyager au Japon
c'était premier juillet 2005
bon
ben trop à Tokyo au Japon c'est loin de
moi et ben je rappelle le principe le
principe c'est d'aller chez les gens de
voir un petit peu comment ils vivent de
se faire inviter à dîner de se faire
inviter à dormir tout ça avec des
rencontres qui sont faites complètement
spontanément dans la rue sans aucune
préparation d'ailleurs je précise que je
voyage seul et là ici au Japon mais je
sais pas ce que ça va donner parce que
premièrement j'y suis jamais allé Dylan
tu rêves d'aller où toi dans quel pays
oh là là moi j'aimerais bien aller au
Québec Québec j'adore
aussi
oui vous dormez chez tellement vous
allez me frapper à tellement de portes
vous dormez chez tellement d'inconnu etc
vous avez sous les propositions à
descente d'habitants d'habitants c'est
extrêmement dézo c'est même insultant
alors ce qui est arrivé ce qui est
arrivé parfois petite c'est plutôt tu
sais la maman qui dit c'était au Pérou
qui me dit tu veux pas épouser ma fille
regarde
mais je sais pas si c'était mon charme
ou le fait que j'arrive d'un pays plus
riche
va jamais là-bas
on va revoir on va le revoir on l'avait
revu l'an dernier shadown quand tu avais
sauté du toit d'une voiture et alors
c'est pas ta plus grande cascade Antoine
faire un petit plaisir un petit truc
juste pour moi une petite pause petite
pause Z
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a parlé tu as parlé de la vidéo t'as
parlé dans quand tu étais au Caraïbes
que il y a une
fusillade sur la terrasse c'est un truc
de fou regardez ça
[Musique]
je le sentais je sais pas du tout ce qui
s'est passé
je regrette juste c'est que j'ai pas
fait un plan de tout le bar qui se vidéo
en 10 secondes là j'ai pas de réflexe de
tourner la télé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez pas peur parfois de faire une
proposition et que elle appelle son mari
vous fassez casser la figure etc bah non
je demande d'ailleurs elle dit non je
dis appeler votre mari
[Musique]
mais pas pour des trucs comme ça je pose
une question on va pas me sur alors oui
Géraldine est-ce que depuis la crise du
covid ça a changé même si maintenant
c'est derrière nous est-ce que les gens
aujourd'hui sont plus suspicieux
qu'avant est-ce qu'il vous accueille
moins facilement chez eux est-ce que ça
a changé la donne non quand j'ai tourné
le l'épisode Costa Rica qui était le
premier que je faisais pour RMC
découverte
il y avait le masque dans les rues au
Costa Rica et je pensais que ça allait
être très dur en fait en ville c'était
impossible mais quand je suis arrivé
dans les campagnes
et il y en avait surtout qui considérait
que le covid c'était une c'était une
invention il y a de tous les gens sont
variés en fait tu parlais de la Corée du
Nord tout à l'heure en tout cas en Corée
du Sud on se rappelle je voulais juste
revoir encore cet extrait un peu trop
abusé sur la colle du coin
et c'est vrai que tu étais bien dans tes
bien entamé en ville regarde
[Musique]
normalement j'aime bien dormir chez les
gens mais dans un état où je suis je
vais pas dormir i things
Hello
[Rires]
[Musique]
you look you look dark Vador white
en fait on a une demi-heure parce que
j'étais dans un état second mais j'ai
quand même réussi à changer mes
cassettes et ça a tourné tourné tourné
et comme me disait mon producteur donc
il y en a une demi-heure et comme disait
mon producteur tu t'es vu quand tu as vu
il y a un autre truc aussi
je veux pas de cigarettes je fume pas de
pétard parce que j'arrive pas à fumer
des cigarettes je me suis dit là bon
pour l'émission machin etc ça me faisait
rien donc je croyais que ça faisait rien
ou pas grand chose
en fait j'étais mal et j'avais perdu la
notion du temps donc j'avais
l'impression que j'en avais pour des
mois
donc non non
le 8 mars dernier je suis passé une
soirée avec Daniel et moi aussi j'avais
perdu la notion du temps
qui tourne et tu t'endors
et là non tu t'endors pas tu t'en merde
oh là là là là
[Applaudissements]